I'll be dogged sylia the cure thing a
piano store in Dortmund Germany AHA
makhmud sings about serious Yarmouk camp
south of downtown Damascus home to over
100,000 Palestinian refugees ah-hum is
from Yarmouk where people now live under
brutal extremist rule with food and
medicine in short supply even when
people are hungry they still love music
and songs our music gives people hope
for them were like a little light in the
dark today Ahmed is a refugee again he
sings for others like him who fled Syria
to escape Islamic state before he left
in is fighter Kotik mod trying to move
his piano through Yarmouk and set it on
fire he said what's that is that a piano
don't you know that music is forbidden
he poured benzene over my piano and then
bye-bye piano like Naveen it's not a
good idea to try to reason with these
men you just go home defeat on pathology
lemon silica I took I have more than a
month to get to Germany he says he had
to pay human traffickers the entire way
many of his friends here in Dortmund are
also from Yarmouk ahmed says he wants to
apply for asylum and start a new life
here I want to study in Germany and play
music but first I need to have my
children and my wife with me they're in
danger and I'm afraid they could be
arrested or a bomb could fall on them
Achmed hopes to play in a concert hall
one day and to own his own piano again
how they worship young for me a piano is
like a brother we played together and
went through so much together back in
Yarmouk sake but even it's one dream
that looks set to come true a piano
maker has already promised I ham a new
instrument